[موسيقى]
الكافيار الأبيض من ألبينو ستور هو
فقط نادرا جدا لأن جدا
قلة من الحيوانات تصنع كافيار ألبينو
يضاف الذهب لتجفيفه
هو أغلى غذاء في العالم
ما بين 100،000 يورو و كيلوغرام
[موسيقى]
قول الشيء نفسه لوالتر جرين اليوم
فرحة كبيرة أو معنا منذ أكثر من 30 عامًا
سنوات الشغف معنا
تبدأ أو معي 34 عاما جيدا
بدأ منجم الصيد
قبعة كرة القدم تعني مزرعة الأسماك الخضراء
مكان جميل للحيوانات والعيش فيه
حيث لديهم الوقت للنمو
تصرف بنضج
هذه دورة وفي النهاية
سنحصل على منتج خاص في
القضية هي أن sakari albino carius
المنتج جعله معروفًا لنا بشكل أفضل
لكن هذا هو ستوهر الأبيض
بالطبع أندر بكثير من
كل الآخرين ما عدا سمك السلمون المرقط و
char k قد نحتاج إلى اثنين
أو ثلاث سنوات لحصاد الكافيار
مقدرة
ثم لا تهتم لأطول فترة ممكنة
تأخذ اليوم إلى الغد قطع يحسب
أن الأمر يستغرق من 14 إلى 16 عامًا
يمكنك حصاد الكافيار
يمكنك استخدام غلافنا الأبيض مع الجميع
الناس يأكلون يخدمون للشراء منا
هذه ، من بين أشياء أخرى ، فنادق رائعة
أو الأفراد مرة أخرى
يقول إنه يريد تعليقه لأن الآخرين
طعم windsheim ظهر اليد
كل إنسان ينضم من أجل الفودكا
المنتج يقرر لنفسه
استمتع بلطف باتريك الفم
ببساطة تجربة طعم رائعة
لكنه كلف نفسه حقا
حاول تذوق
هذا هو الشيء المهم